que c'est pas parce qu'on a un beau
bateau une belle bagnole un bel
appartement et un bel enfant qu'on est
en amour ça c'est vrai
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes ici ce soir
parce que je n'ai pas suivi Secret Story
4 et j'aimerais que vous me fassiez un
résumé alors qui a gagné la bimbo le
cinglé la [__] ou le [__]
[Applaudissements]
je crois que c'est le [__]
très bien et c'est vrai que cette année
ils ont tous été vendus à un cirque
après l'émission
non je les ai trouvés pour certains
plutôt touchants et je trouve que Benoît
parce qu'on en parlait et est un garçon
qui fait pas le le cake en sortant peut
faire quelque chose alors Benjamin en
paix nous serons tous les deux nous
parlerons de vous de vos origines votre
famille de votre carrière et du livre
que vous publiez à l'occasion du 25e
anniversaire de la mort de votre
grand-mère Simone Signoret qui donc n'a
pas pu vous voir habiller en fille
présenter Secret Story non c'est dommage
ça leur avait fait rigoler je pense
j'espère en tous les cas alors Benjamin
rebonsoir après un premier livre
familial qui s'appelait maintenant il
faudra tout se dire qu'elle fait du
bruit en dévoilant les relations
ambiguës qui avaient entretenu Yves
Montand avec sa fille adoptive Catherine
allégré votre maman vous publiez dans
les yeux de Simone avec 300 photos
l'album de famille que vous n'aviez pas
que je n'avais pas j'ai pas de photo de
famille j'ai une photo avec ma
grand-mère pas de photo de
d'anniversaire pas de photos de Noël pas
de photos de Jour de l'An rien du tout
je pense que la maison comme des photos
tout le temps dansait pas en famille
voilà c'est un manque hein c'est
terrible ça franchement quand on repense
aux années passées ça fait ça peut faire
de la peine ouais donc je me suis fait
mon bouquin à moi voilà alors vous avez
recueilli dans les agences des photos de
Simone Signoret de 1940 à 1985 alors
dernière fois vous avez vu votre
grand-mère Simone Signoret vous aviez 15
ans vous quittiez la propriété familiale
d'Auteuil en laissant une vieille dame
assise devant ses mots croisés clope au
bec lunettes sur le nez vous ne saviez
pas qu'elle avait un cancer du pancréas
et qu'elle était condamnée c'est vrai
quand je suis parti de la campagne je
suis parti avec la science d'un garçon
de 15 ans qui pense la revoir le
week-end d'après et j'en ai jamais revu
alors vous prendrez conscience du
monstre sacré qui était mamie Simone le
jour de sa mort parce que quand je fais
la route qui me sépare de la maison de
campagne d'Auteuil toutes les radios
font le parcours de ma grand-mère je
connaissais comme ça mais quand on se
rend compte que l'Oscar qu'on a côtoyé
250 000 fois et qui est sur le piano on
sait jamais demandé qu'est-ce que
c'était pour quel film en quelle année
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé on se dit bon
Dieu tu es quand même passé à côté de
tout et c'est pareil pour le lait de
Kennedy c'est pareil pour les disques
d'or c'est pareil pour les Britanniques
words c'est pareil pour tout à 15 ans on
pense aux filles au tennis à faire du
sport et pas à l'histoire de ses
grands-parents c'est un peu dommage
alors vous comprenez à ce moment-là que
c'est pas une mamie ordinaire elle est
mort sans avoir eu le temps de vous
raconter qu'est-ce que d'or Gabin
Hollywood en revanche il a eu le temps
de vous conseiller de lire ce que j'ai
pas fait j'ai vu des murs tapissés avec
les intégrales de Flaubert etzola vous
êtes dit Zola j'ai fait un peu
l'intégrale Flaubert c'est un peu chiant
j'ai essayé j'ai quand même fait
Maupassant je me suis fait un semblant
de culture forcer contre vous vous
préfériez à les piquer les bouquins
érotiques dans la chambre
les
féminines après la mort de votre
grand-mère ils vont parler de Marilyn
Monroe c'est quelqu'un qui avait besoin
de parler de sexe en permanence et que
il m'a raconté avec force et détails sa
relation avec Maëline et quand on
l'écoute c'est évidemment pas de sa
faute il a rien voulu faire avec
Marie-Line qui a tout fait Thierry c'est
vrai
elle a tout voulu et c'est vrai que mon
temps c'était un séducteur dans l'âme il
va passer une femme il faut qu'il y ait
une séduction il faut qu'il se passe
quelque chose mon temps était comme ça
et c'est vrai que que il parlait de sexe
assez librement et bon bah c'est bien ça
m'a pris plein de choses alors après son
Oscar votre grand-mère rentre en Europe
elle laisse Yves Montand finir avec
Maryline un film au titre prédestiné
let's make love et ce qui devait arriver
évidemment Simone avait eu l'Oscar et
Marilyn en remontant quoi elle aura pas
longtemps
il est rentré finalement donc c'est ce
qui compte et que ma grand-mère quelque
part est pardonnée elle a dit vous
connaissez beaucoup d'hommes qui aurait
pu résister à Maryline on peut pas dire
mieux
en même temps c'est là que votre
grand-mère commence à grossir elle boit
et elle se venge d'une certaine façon
alors en offrant ça déchéance à mon
temps c'est vrai qu'il y a un avant et
un après c'est vrai que ma grand-mère a
devancé l'âge et c'est vrai qu'elle a
accéléré considérablement son
vieillissement et quand je vois ma mère
qui a le même âge que ma grand-mère
quand elle est mort 64 ans que je les
compare
beaucoup mieux alors mon temps
évidemment souffrait de ce que votre
grand-mère était devenu il a cette
phrase terrible il dit être l'amant de
Casque d'or c'était facile mais il a
fallu beaucoup d'amour pour aimer Madame
Rosa mais c'est pas pour aimer pour
rester c'est encore pire bah oui mais en
même temps c'est tellement honnête il
faut accepter et je pense que dans leur
couple il y a ces petits arrangements
qu'il faut qu'un couple dur c'est vrai
entre une femme qui accepte son mari
vivent sa vie d'homme et un homme qui
accepte que sa femme vieillisse
finalement ça fait une belle histoire
c'est ce qu'il faudra retenir au final
pour rester ensemble faut le décider
exactement alors Simone Signoret était
une femme engagée politiquement vous
vous dites vous imaginez que je commence
à discourir sur le Darfour Benjamin
Castaldi bouleversé par le sort de sa
kiné bonne blague en présentant des
émissions vides de sens je suis condamné
à la fermer quand vous dites des
émissions vite de son ça veut dire vous
les faites uniquement pour l'argent
finalement je dis dont on dit qu'elles
sont vides de sens moi j'ai la chance de
faire un métier que j'aime qui est celui
d'animer des émissions des grands
spectacles des grands shows il y a pas
de pandémissement que cela à la
télévision on est en direct ça fait 10
ans que j'ai fait les plus grosses
émissions du PAF français j'ai fait la
Nouvelle Star j'ai fait le loft j'ai
fait secrète sans prétention je pense
que j'ai acquis certaines une certaine
connaissance et une certaine maturité
là-dedans je me régale à le faire
évidemment c'est pas du Baudelaire c'est
pas du Rimbaud et c'est pas du
millénoton on est tous d'accord pas
encore cohabiterons je sais pas mais
voilà moi je le fais avec avec cœur et
le jour où j'aurais pu le faire je le
ferai plus alors je vais très bien payé
pour le faire c'est vrai mais mais cet
argent d'abord je le mets au service de
la création puisque ma société
j'ai importante ce que je vais dire ma
société est récupère 100% de mes revenus
d'animateurs c'est-à-dire que je
redistribue avec les collaborateurs que
je paye pour créer pour produire donc
c'est pas pour moi à 100% non non il y a
pas de mal à aimer l'argent de toute
façon moi j'ai jamais promis avec ça
j'ai eu tendance à une époque à dire
l'argent c'est bien bah ouais c'est vrai
je préfère rouler en ferraille en deux
chevaux je le dirai plus parce que après
on vous dit que c'est qui ce petit
comble bling bling je dis maintenant je
roule en deux chevaux même si c'est pas
vrai non mais c'est vrai que vous n'avez
pas attendu d'être célèbre pour faire
des conneries pour l'argent
l'épisode rocambolesque vous partez à
Los Angeles relancer la carrière de la
chanteuse Esther Galilée
qui avait fait ce tube phénoménal vous
étiez plus mais le roi des cons hein
mais c'est marrant c'est à dire que plus
con que moi à cette époque là il y avait
pas je sais pas ce qui me guider à cette
époque mais je me suis barré là-bas
pendant trois quatre mois j'ai mené
grand train et j'ai pris le train au cul
en fait je sais pourquoi vous aimez
l'argent parce que vous avez toujours
l'image de mon temps arrivant à Auteuil
en Ferrari
275 GTB du métal j'étais précédé par le
son du V12 donc là vous vous dites c'est
ça être un mec et d'ailleurs à l'époque
où vous êtes à Los Angeles pour rester à
Galil à un moment vous êtes assis à
l'arrière d'une limousine qui fait 8
mètres de long et à ce moment-là vous
dites je suis montant exactement donc en
fait c'est peut-être pour ça tout
simplement
mais euh mais c'est vrai moi mon temps
l'image que j'ai de cet homme
extraordinaire c'est que il était
toujours bien habillé sur le costard
tiret 4 épingles ils m'ont dans sa
bagnole quand il monte dans sa bagnole
lui c'est pas comme nous on a l'air de
rien mais lui c'est toujours artistique
c'est toujours beau bon effectivement il
est il a tout réussi quand il prend une
voiture c'est une belle bagnole quand il
a une femme c'est la plus belle du monde
enfin bon ce luxe que vous adorez il y a
pas de mal à aimer le lux c'est ce qui
vous a pas coûté trop cher il vous a
coûté Flavie parce que elle arrête
de partir en disant elle est partie en
disant il y avait trop de luxe c'est une
connerie on va le dire c'est une
connerie absolue euh moi quand je suis
avec une femme et j'essaie de lui rendre
la vie belle si je peux l'emmener sur un
bateau de tremblent plutôt qu'un
zodiaque je préfère le bateau 35 m par
contre c'est vrai que c'est pas parce
qu'on a un beau bateau une belle bagnole
un bel appartement et un bel enfant
qu'on est en amour ça c'est vrai alors
Catherine Allégret votre maman dit de
vous il a beaucoup de talents beaucoup
de capacités il est allé à la facilité
si le bossait un peu plus sur d'autres
trucs il pourrait prendre un virage
est-ce que ce virage vous avez envie de
le prendre pas maintenant mais il va
falloir que je le prenne un jour parce
que vous rêvez d'un talk show quotidien
avant avant le 20h par exemple j'aurais
rêvé de tirer Ardisson
[Applaudissements]
sur la culture et sur la connaissance
pour finir un truc je comprends pas vous
avez déclaré je me déteste je ne m'aime
ni en photo ni à la télé non mais
pourquoi
Benji
mentalement
je vous dis pas ça pour qu'on dise oh et
qu'on a Venise je
ne m'aime pas parce que je sais
pertinemment venant de là où je viens
que mon accomplissement intellectuel
culturel artistique n'est pas fait dans
le métier que je fais on va pas se
mentir il faudra un jour que je me
prouve autre chose qu'est-ce que j'ai
déjà fait
nous on vous aime vous êtes cash vous
êtes sincère et ça c'est plutôt rare
dans les endos une grande qualité et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu